JOEL LEWIS: Hi.
My name is Joel Lewis.
At the time of this
recording in 2010
I'm a graduate student in
the Math Department at MIT,
and I'm also a TA for OCW
Scholar 18.01 and 18.02.
CHRISTINE BREINER: Hi.
I'm Christine Breiner.
I'm a Moore Instructor here
at MIT and for OCW Scholar,
I'll be a teaching assistant
for 18.01 and for 18.02.
DAVID JORDAN: My
name is David Jordan
and I'm a graduate
student here at MIT.
And I'm a TA for
OpenCourseWare Scholar 18.02.
So I thought I would say a
little bit about what we do
with recitations here at MIT.
So, the purpose
of the recitations
is for you to apply
what you've learned
in lecture towards solving
specific concrete problems
and then for you to compare
your solutions to those problems
with those of your TA.
CHRISTINE BREINER: The
purpose of the recitations
on OCW Scholar is
really the same purpose
that David described for
recitations here at MIT.
What we want you to do
is have an opportunity
to work varying
levels of problems
and then see us give detailed
solutions to those problems
so that you can see how we
think about mathematics.
JOEL LEWIS: Almost
all of our videos
have a natural
moment where you can
pause after the
problem's been stated.
And we really strongly
suggest you work out
the problem on a piece of paper
before going back to the video
and seeing our solutions.
This will help
you do mathematics
rather than be able
just to see mathematics.
Hope you enjoy the course.